[Applause]
please welcome nabin salem
i'm uh i'm very honored to meet you
i really love your story
how did you end up on this trip in the
first place so i mean really the reason
behind it is my dad and he's from
tanzania along with my grandparents and
great grandparents we have a long
family history in east africa and also
at the same time my daughters were all
about under the age of five and so i
packed my bags one day and went to
dharasalam tanzania to see what was
going on in the world and you know
wanted to see like what's missing what
what needs to be done what action needs
to be taken
and i started to learn about
malnutrition and
understood that 8 000 children a day
were dying from something that is 100
preventable which is hunger and
malnutrition
so just looking into my own daughter's
eyes right and understanding that
mothers every single day are losing
their children to something that we know
how to treat and i really felt that
urgency
because obviously i didn't have a lot of
free time at that moment with all of
these little kids to take care of but
that urgency really stayed with me and
it kept me up at night and i knew that i
had to do something about it and i
didn't have any experience i'd never
worked for a non-profit before
i have no manufacturing experience
nothing but i was like if we don't do
something then lives are at stake and
this is an opportunity and a
responsibility to do something at that
moment and take action i mean
where did you go
like
where did you start you know
did people take you seriously what was
what was your first
lesson that we could all learn from yeah
i mean i traveled with a bunch of
different non-profits and i learned
about their philosophies their mandates
how they worked and i came home and i
said i want to do this completely
differently and i remember having a
follow-up call with them and saying i
have this idea to start a business but
it's a non-profit but it's a business
and and so we can do something at scale
we can feed these children at scale and
they said that's not how it's done
and so for 24 hours i was really sad
that my idea was terrible idea and then
i thought to myself wait a second i've
only been in this business for 20
minutes 24 hours these people have been
in for 20 years maybe they've just been
there too long maybe this is the way of
the future let's give it a try so i just
picked myself back up and i'm like we're
going to go for it and we're going to
make this food at scale and we're going
to try to reach thousands and millions
of children and make it happen
so
you have helped more than two million
kids um last year
um
and
what now
is your goal
the need in the world has doubled so
what i need to do now is double the size
of our factory so we're trying to raise
money now to be able to buy the
equipment that we need to be able to
produce more of these packets i brought
one with me so we make a million five of
these every single day we work 24 hours
a day making this product called
plumping up
i have 110 people who are on my team we
work 24 hours a day to be able to
deliver these products to 60 countries
i'm
did you put money from your own pocket
into this endeavor yes yes but we also
you know
i take loans from banks i make
partnerships we raise money so it's
really a little bit of everything but
definitely there's a personal investment
as well
well we heard that purdue farms has
actually been a big supporter of yours
and we are thrilled to tell you um that
through working with them we've actually
um
yep here comes the big check we've
raised 25 thousand dollars
courtesy of purdue
and
[Music]
i um
uh chris miller my producing partner and
i want to match that also um so
thank you
thank you
so much for everything that you do
um
thank you oh my god nathan go to the
drewberrymore drewberrymareshow.com to
find out more about nathan's mission to
end world hunger and know how you can
help start today thank you
[Music]
you